at the early stages of season one of the
show commodore family seemed like your
normal family living on the mountainside
but that couldn't be further from the
truth they possessed the legendary
breathing style sun breathing that was
passed on throughout the generations and
leads all the way back to the strongest
demon slayer to ever live yorichi
tsugikuni and that's where our story
starts yorichi was a legendary demon
slayer who lived nearly 500 years ago
during the sengoku era also called the
golden age of demon slayers he's the
progenitor of breathing styles being the
one who created the original sun
breathing and the only demon slayer ever
that muzan kibutsuji was afraid of apart
from being the only user of sun
breathing he was also by far the
greatest swordsman in the world even as
a seven-year-old child with no training
he was capable of easily defeating a
trained swordsman the very first time he
picked up a sword striking him in
multiple areas across his body faster
than the eye can process his
swordsmanship was so great that a battle
doll modeled after him had to be made
with six arms wielding katanas and
utilizing 108 techniques to even attempt
to imitate yorichi's skills and even
then the doll was still vastly inferior
compared to him his might easily
overwhelmed the demon king muzan and
even in his 80s he was far stronger than
the upper rank one kokushibu his younger
brother he initially created sun
breathing with twelve techniques all
connected to one another later upon
meeting the demon king himself yorichi
perfected a swordsmanship style creating
a new unnamed 13th form since some
breathing techniques are so closely tied
to kamado family let's quickly go
through all of them the first and most
common form is dance where the user
delivers a single high-powered vertical
slash as seen in tanjido's battle
against rui clear blue sky the user
spins their body horizontally to deliver
a 360 degree slash raging sun the user
unleashes two horizontal slashes to hit
or defend from incoming attacks burning
bones summer sun the user unleashes a
large circular slash that defends from
imminent frontal attacks setting sun
transformation the user backflips into
the air to deliver a powerful upended
sword slash that aims to decapitate
their target solar heat haze the user
charges towards the target unleashing a
horizontal slash seemingly covered in
the haze that fails to land but actually
does hit the target beneficent radiance
the user spirals into the air and
delivers a powerful slash that surrounds
the enemy sunflower thrust the user
unleashes a single thrust attack with
the point of the blade dragon sun halo
head dance the user unleashes a
continuous fast and powerful sword
attack that seemingly takes the form of
a japanese dragon made of solar flames
fire wheel the user leaps behind the
opponent and spins in the air downward
releasing a sword attack in a circular
motion fake rainbow the user performs
high speed twists and rotations thus
creating after images flame dance a two
combo strike that starts with the
vertical slash and then a horizontal one
right after 13th form the user
continuously performs all 12 forms of
sun breathing in repetitive succession
to increase the accuracy and agility of
its movements this form was created
solely for the purpose of killing muzan
kibutsuji since the repetition of all 12
forms aims to destroy muzan's 12 vital
organs 7 hearts and 5 brains that move
freely inside his body so how did the
kamado family come in possession of this
legendary breathing style well sometime
during the sengoku era yodeji met
sumiyoshi and sister of the kamado
family yoruchi saved sumiyoshi
presumably from a demon and they became
close friends he would then often visit
the kamados in their home in the
mountain one time while staying with
them sumiyoshi and his wife asked
yorichi if he could perform his
sun-breathing style in front of them he
of course accepted performing all the
forms with such grace he was likened
more like a spirit than a human
sumiyoshi would closely observe these
demonstrations and keep them in his
memories on this last visit yoruchi gave
sumiyoshi his hanafuda earrings
sumiyoshi who looked up to yoruci
promised to pass the sun breathing
techniques along with hanafuda earrings
onto his further generations he later
named it hinokami kagura and it became a
family tradition the hinokami kagura was
passed on from father to son in a form
of dance the kamado family used the
breathing style within a ritual ceremony
practiced every new year where the
breathing style user would offer the
fire god a dance from sunset to sunrise
to ward off threats and diseases the
hinokamikagura dance was created with 12
different segments each one presenting a
different form of sun breathing
eventually the hinokami kagura was
passed on to tanjuro kamado who used it
in a similar way as his ancestors
tanjuro was the head of the kamado
family being the father of our
protagonists tanjido and nezuko he died
a few years prior to the main story due
to his illness although there isn't much
information about him from flashbacks we
can assume that he was a loving and
caring person he had a peaceful
relationship with his family and
regularly lectured tanjido about life
according to tanjido he didn't like
standing out or displaying his true
abilities to others however if his
family was in danger he wouldn't
hesitate to protect them and he would
show no mercy toward the enemy at some
point in his life tanjiro married kai
and had six children with her despite
possessing the legendary breathing style
he never showed interest in joining the
demon slayers and chose to spend his
time with his family instead although he
died some time before tanjido joined the
demon slayers he was a great inspiration
to him and the person who introduced him
to sun breathing not many people
realized this but tanjuro was actually
one of the strongest humans around at
the time he was shown to be a
phenomenally strong individual despite
not being a demon slayer and having a
tragic disease that makes his body
incredibly frail he was able to slay a
bear more than two meters tall with
incredible speed without even wielding a
niche sword what's also impressive is
that he was able to access the
transparent world tanjuro stated that he
learned this from his father in the form
of perception training and was able to
use it proficiently against a giant bear
chopping the animal twice in the blink
of an eye before it could even react
tanjuro's birthmark on his forehead is
secretly a demon slayer mark this is
proven by shinjuro's explanation that
all sun breathing users naturally have a
mark on their forehead for those of you
who don't know what transparent world is
let us explain demon slayers that have
awakened the demon slayer mark can
utilize a special form of perception
that alters their vision allowing them
to perceive other living beings as if
they were transparent only being able to
see the inner workings of their bodies
most notably users are able to perceive
the flow of blood breathing muscular
contractions and joint movements of the
creature that they are looking at one
can use the transparent world's power to
see inside an enemy's body as a way to
predict and evade their opponent's
attacks as well as to find openings for
their own strikes additionally the user
is able to perceive the world around
them as if it was in slow motion thus
dramatically increasing their movement
speed and reflexes with all this
information in mind it would be very
interesting to see how strong would
tangier be if he trained as a demon
slayer the first time we met hashidas
none of them had access to the
transparent world and they didn't even
know what demon slayer marks are if not
for his illness he would surely be able
to rise to the rank of the hashida and
possibly become the strongest demon
slayer in his generation throughout his
entire life kanjuro emanated absolutely
no sense of hatred anger or fear even in
dire situations this is greatly inspired
by yodeji's capability to stop his
bloodlust for combat tanjuro also had
immense stamina and endurance for a
non-demon slayer being able to practice
the hinokami kagura ritual dance from
dusk to dawn without any rest despite
his illness frail body and freezing
surroundings we couldn't possibly make a
video on hinokamikagura without
mentioning everyone's favorite
sun-breathing user tanjiro kamado at the
beginning of his journey as a demon
slayer tanjiro didn't even know what
breathing forms are let her know what
sun breathing is although he witnessed
his father performing hinokamikagura in
the past he was completely unaware of
what it is he initially trained under
sakonji the former water hashira and
learned water breathing techniques from
him on his mission to avenge his family
and defeat muzan kibutsuji tanjido faced
many different demons in the beginning
those demons were weak and he was easily
able to behead them using the water
breathing style however with time his
enemies became exponentially stronger
and the water breathing style he was
taught was simply not enough to keep him
alive during his near-death experience
in his battle against rui tanjido
recalled the memory of his father
showing him the hinokami kagura in a
form of dance simply by recalling the
single memory he was able to instantly
adapt his water breathing and
immediately change it to the
hinokamikagura in the middle of battle
now performing a technique this advanced
simply because you saw it once wouldn't
be possible for anyone we can only
assume that since the kamado family
practiced the same style for over 400
years it's literally in their blood and
they easily master it without long
training as tanjido's body was more
suited to the hinokami kagura he quickly
overpowered the lower ranked demon
however the sheer force of fatigue it
placed on his untrained body caused him
to collapse only moments after using it
thus in battles he usually saves it as
his last choice only using it when it's
completely necessary tanjido trained
more so that his body could take the
strain of hinokamikagura techniques and
was capable of using multiple forms in
succession in his battle against daki
although the whiplash from doing so
became quickly apparent still through
battling hantengu and undergoing intense
training during the swordsman's village
arc and the hashida training arc tanjido
finally managed to master all the forms
in the hinokamikagura using it to its
full potential against akaza when
tanjido witnessed all the forms
performed by yorichi tsugikuni himself
he realized his own hinokami kagura
moves had unnecessary movements
different wrist angles footwork and
breathing rhythm removing all these
mistakes enabled him to awaken the true
form of a legendary sun breathing and he
was able to temporarily battle on equal
grounds with the demon king muzan to the
point that muzan saw yorichi's visage
overlapping with tanjido's own when he
was performing the techniques against
him click on this video where we explain
the entire story of yorichi tsugikuni i
know you're still here click it